Jocelyn you say we are not our emotions
can you explain it certainly feels it I
hope people really don't like it when I
take away their emotions but uh yeah no
we're not our emotions we do love them
you know us just saying if you if you
think about this if you accept the fact
that we Are Spiritual Beings in bodies
we are energetic beings in bodies so we
gave ourselves this body we have
since you know we have touch taste sight
all Miracle right with all this we can
make other babies new people we can do
all these things and we have this
emotion we are here as energetic beings
the universe has created all itself in
all of these now I don't know how many
people are on the planet but it's way
too many
to experience itself
what better way to experience anything
than emotion
we love emotion but emotion is a product
of our thinking
if we're not thinking we're not
emotional we get emotional because we
think I lost it we left me I don't have
my man anymore we cry we're emotionally
it didn't get the job they don't like me
we're emotional because I'm afraid I'm
gonna die you're not dead but the bear
is coming and so your body goes I'm
afraid I'm gonna die I'm gonna die you
know it's kicked up by you know thoughts
so if we're not our thoughts we're not
our emotions we are energetic beings in
bodies here to have an experience
and you know emotion is a great way to
do it emotion also produces energy you
know
um I I saw this with both my parents in
in their latter years when you know they
were getting close to leaving
my mother was very dramatic and she
could be dramatic over eggs she could be
dramatic over butter she I mean big
drama it's not right she was a little
affected it's not right I can't believe
they sent me this they know how long
have they know me they've known me I
think it's hostile hostile to send me
this kind of fun and I would watch her
and it's like
when people kick that up it splatters on
you and then you it's very infectious
and then you get mad at them and you go
you know do you have to really seriously
does it have to be like this I mean
you've done this my whole life I don't
like it and now you're in this emotional
thing
so I think I write about it one day I
was in the kitchen my mother was really
carrying on about something she was also
blind uh I mean not completely but
almost
and she she was old and she was alone
and cranky and she was carrying on and I
was getting so mad at her because you
know I was just home for a trip and
trying to have a good time and really we
were just making eggs
and I decided because I had had so much
training with meditation I decided I'm
just gonna observe her which is also
what I teach just watch her without
being her daughter without having this
history together you know we all have
our history with our parents and we're
so judgmental and out to be you're wrong
and I'm right and you're worse than I am
and I'm better and whatever it is so I
decided I'm just going to Observer and I
just went into that space and she was
carrying on and and you know I began to
see
that she was unhappy and that she was
old
and that she was kicking up this emotion
because it gave her energy and it made
her feel more energetic and Alive
because otherwise she wanted to feel
like I just I'm almost gone I'm not here
so you know
we're not our emotions but we will
utilize them in different ways we'll use
them to make other people feel guilty
we'll use them to get sympathy we'll use
them to convince ourselves of certain
things mostly we're just using them for
the experience of them love you know
this neutral space that I'm talking
about kind of is love but it's not like
the love that we think about because
most of the time with love that we think
about we're all wrapped up with emotion
do they love me back as much as I love
them you know love gets all complicated
but this space of no thinking no emotion
this space of Stillness where higher
Consciousness inspiration and you can
connect to your soul same space
where this other kind of language can
occur
that has no emotion and it has no
thinking
so as an actor or a writer filmmaker
don't we need those emotions though
because we're going to at some point put
a project out there that's going to you
know affect people in some way so we
need to really tap into that well yeah I
mean everybody loves emotion nobody's
going to want to give up their emotion
and we're never going to give up our
emotion we love our emotion I think
we've taken advantage of of you know
filmmakers have taken advantage of our
emotions by you know same thing as
corporate you know I want to I'm going
to sell this movie on fear
you know I'm gonna I
listen I I did a horror movie I hate to
say this because maybe somebody will go
look it up
I don't like horror movies I was sent
this script when I was young and my
husband I closed the script my husband
came in and I was crying and he said why
are you crying and I said oh because
they're going to ask me to do this movie
they're gonna ask me to leave this movie
and I'm gonna probably say yes
and he goes well you don't have to me I
know but it's leading the movie so I
made the movie
um
and then you know it's that has a cult
following but then the director made
another movie like that and then he made
another movie like that and I think when
you make one genre movie like that to
sort of get yourself known and show I
can do a structure within a you know
this kind of filmmaking you know this
genre of filmmaking and I can put a
structure together in actors and direct
them and here's my camera and you know
show off those things by entering a
genre of picture like that where women
are killed because most of them are
about killing women you know I think you
get one
I mean this is sort of like a little
opinionated there but I think you get
one you get one okay you got you on the
map you can't go on making movies about
killing women without making a pretty
crappy statement you know so I think
that they're taking advantage of but you
know this is all part of us kind of
rising up and above because once you see
that you go I'm not gonna you're not
gonna manipulate my emotions because I'm
the only one who can do that I can have
them and I can leave them or I if I
can't leave them I can at least look at
them I can at least separate myself out
and look at them and going boy I'm
crying so hard there is not coming out
of my nose and running down my lip and
I'm just looking at that just that
separation alone will make you realize I
am not that
that emotion it's just part of this life
in a body that I'm creating
and it's kind of cool
it's kind of cool it's not you know like
oh no it's kind of cool that's why we're
watching the movies oh it's cool cool
and oh look they're they're they're
emulating that emotion look oh he's
scared she looks really scared oh
screaming she's really screaming
you know it's
anyway did I answer that yeah I think so
but one good thing is then we know once
we leave the theater or we turn it off
at home that it's over it's not but but
I just wondered you know how does an
artist separate
um their need for emotion to put it into
their projects versus dealing with them
every day well I think it's great you
brought it up again because the the be
on end all of it is they honor the fact
that they're creating it
we're creating it in life and we're
creating it for the film and we're
creating it for the play We're creating
it an actor has to bring that life out
of nothing he creates that before your
very eyes I am not just gonna pretend
that I'm crying I'm gonna cry I'm gonna
do the things that I would do if I was
crying and I'm gonna stimulate that and
then you're gonna enter that and doesn't
that show us both that we're just
creating emotions we can create them we
can uncreate them we can create them we
can walk away from them the actors get
in trouble when they create it and then
they go they think they've had their
part they think they look like better
actors if they say I have trouble
getting rid of the emotions of this part
I have to take them home I have to live
in the emotions you know you know you
don't have to do that you create it you
know you enter and you exit freely
that's what I tell my students enter it
and exit it freely
then you can go as far in as you want
because you know you're going to exit